well after more than a year of wasted
time on the fantasy of Russian collusion
in the 2016 election there still no
evidence that any of it actually
happened that doesn't mean that lives
haven't been destroyed many have been
beginning with george papadapolis who at
the time was a 28 year old unpaid
advisor to the campaign he later pled to
a charge of making false statements to
federal investigators looking into
Russia he has not yet been sentenced
Simona McGee on tape Papadopoulos is his
wife and she joins us tonight mrs.
papadapolis thanks for coming up thank
you for hosting me so you married your
husband after this investigation began
after he'd become famous for his
purported collusion with Russia you're
confident he did not collude in any way
with the Russian government I know he
did not and actually one of the reason
why I'm here tonight thank you for
hosting me first to set the record
straight about George in particularly in
response to James Comey statements on
national TV recently in which he says
that George tried actively to obtain
emails on Hillary Clinton this statement
is completely false George never had any
interaction with Russians he has never
been to Russia either
he never it doesn't speak Russian I
never talked to Russian officials yet is
apparently at the region of the Russia
investigation this is quite paradoxical
for me so my understanding is that all
of this begins in March of 2016 when
he's approached in London by a maltese
professor who has since disappeared with
the offer of information from the
Russians what has happened to that
professor do you know well I know
personally this professor because I used
to work with them the fact that the
computer disappeared is very suspicious
but what I know about this meeting
between George and the professor is that
he was talking casually about an
information that was already in the
public domain at the time they met and
it was about to remain sunny Larry
Clinton we have to understand it was
talking about email on Hillary Clinton
not about the DNC emails it's a
completely different topic it was a
gossip
session very casual that George
volunteer Lee reported to the FBI at the
time of their interview and became the
apparently the reason why people think
he is in the region of anything
so-called collusion but actually never
colluded with the Russian he didn't he
didn't do anything Russia even is a job
but his work was completely focused to
the Middle East in particularly in
Israel
no of course he worked at the Hudson
suit here and was a big proponent of
Israel so this professor who do you
think he was working for what was that
about and where do you think he's gone
what was his agenda I honestly have no
idea my personal opinion which are
shared and different introduces that is
a very shady character
it could be neatly recently I heard
these it doesn't want to appear publicly
because of the the situation is involved
into and directly through Georgia but my
understanding is that was gossiping
about emails and again I remember this
information was already highly
speculated by all media all over the
world at the time so it was not in
secret about that yet as I said it's
very fascinating and actually
frustrating to see my husband at the
center of this investigation for talking
in a bar even the meeting with downer
which apparently in London which
apparently originated the rush
investigation is contested by the same
downer he never confirmed that George
explicitly talk about emails so doesn't
know it's really it doesn't make a lot
of sense where is your husband now he's
under a gag order is my understanding
awaiting sentencing is that right
yes is awaiting sentencing and that's
why I think is very important to set the
record straight right now because there
are a lot of misunderstanding about the
situation about his role I used to say
that his role is very important I used
to compare him to John Dean I never
meant to make this comparison in the
sense that would lead to the president
pitchman actually I think was a key role
because he has been approached by
a different character that let's let's
say spice has been the victim of many
setups not only hope or other setups I'm
sure he will be happy to share this
information when the time is right do
you think that your husband's going to
prison I honestly I know a much
dedicated and committed wasn't the term
campaign I know I did an excellent job I
know is my series of because of this
incident its freedom is challenged and
so I trust in the hope and asked to
President Trump to pardon him I hope you
will okay miss Papadopoulos thank you
very much for coming I appreciate it